you've probably heard about anthos
Google clouds application platform for
modern enterprise environments if you
want a chance to try anthos for yourself
the good news is now you can I'm going
to show you exactly how easy it is to
get started exploring anthos using the
Antho sample deployment when we're done
go ahead and follow the link to our
online tutorial launch your own sample
deployment and try out anthos for
yourself we have a sample application an
online store that's an example of a
modern micro services application that
will run in the multi cluster kubernetes
environment created by our deployment
everything i show you and more is
published as a tutorial and our online
Doc's this is where you want to go to
get started what I'm going to show you
will be running a Google cloud but keep
in mind that anthis is here to help you
build and manage your modern application
workloads
running where your enterprise needs them
whether that's on Google cloud multi
cloud or in hybrid environments the
sample deployment has two clusters for
hosting copies of our application
services there's also a config repo that
we'll use for maintaining all
configuration under version control
we'll access cloud shell from a browser
to edit policies in a clone of the
config repo we'll push are committed
changes to the upstream configure Evo
and then they will get automatically
synchronized across both clusters
pathless config management let's dive
right in we need a project for the
services and resources that the anthro
sample deployment or user create for
this tour we'll start with the new one
and then let's navigate to the anthos
dashboard
we'll need to enable the Athos API and
then again back at the dashboard we can
now launch the deployment you can click
through accept any defaults after around
ten minutes everything will be deployed
configured and running after the
deployment is finished let's go back to
the anthos dashboard to explore the
infrastructure resources that were
created from here we can see overall
health we can go ahead and inspect our
clusters and drill down into individual
clusters and then head over to Cobra ATS
engine or we can see more details
drilling down into physical nodes or we
can see the pods that are scheduled on
them or take a look at the actual
workloads where we can see everything
running across all notes and namespaces
or a specific namespace like the one for
the application
[Music]
now let's take a look at the web
front-end services an ingress show us a
list of all the services with Network
endpoints let's filter on sto ingress
gateway which is the name of the
services hosting the endpoints for our
applications front-end click on one of
these for either of our clusters ingress
manages inbound traffic to our
application and we can see what that
looks like by clicking on the expose
endpoint
looks like the application is working
let's switch view now this web
application is made up of a number of
communicating micro services so let's
see how things look from the internal
traffic perspective of anthos service
mesh back at the anthos dashboard
let's inspect services managed by the
service mesh we've got two views
available the default table view and a
topology view these years provide a
great deal of information without having
to write any custom monitoring code
whatsoever the table view presents us
with essential service metrics like
error rate and percentile latency while
the topology view presents us with a
graph visualization of our workloads and
services from either view we have a way
to drill down into a detailed page for
any service as we can see here using the
shipping service in this service detail
view we can see telemetry details that
provide an overview of the shippi
services performance for use the left
nav and click connected services we can
see inbound and outbound connections for
our shipping service we can even note
that traffic over these connections is
unencrypted by looking at the lock icons
from these pages we're able to inspect
service mesh details but what happens
when there's an issue let's check out
the monitoring built into anthro service
mesh at the table view we can see a
summary at the top of the services were
monitoring with the service level
objective or SLO right now it looks like
none are being monitored for performance
so let's fix that well click into the
shopping cart service to create an SLO
using latency as our indicator of
performance and choosing a very low
threshold like 5 milliseconds with a
goal of 90% compliance or a 1-day
rolling period
this will let us see an example of what
it looks like when we have service
performance that exceeds our daily error
budget after we submit this s low we can
easily see it in the health panel let's
go back to our services table we can see
that we've now upgraded to have only 10
services without s ellos for the
shipping car service with an SLO we can
see that our intentionally aggressive
objective as foot as fast our error
budget now let's look at how to better
secure our service traffic as an
e-commerce application data security is
critical to our enterprise and customers
we need to ensure our services are only
using encrypted traffic but recall that
we noticed earlier our shipping service
had an open lock revealing that
unencrypted traffic can pass through an
'this lets us easily fix this with an
encryption policy applying through
configuration so we don't even have to
touch the service code ass activate
cloud shell so we can make some changes
to configuration to be able to access
our project to make changes from the
cloud shell environment we'll need to
ensure that we have a few tools
installed we'll be using Cube control a
clone of our configuration repository to
synchronize our changes and the cube
config environment for our project while
source an initialization script into our
shell environment that takes care of all
of this for us so we're ready to go
once this is all done let's set to the
config repo clone directory then let's
use the integrated editor to quickly
edit our mesh policy so we can tighten
up our restrictions by getting rid of
permissive mode and by requiring mutual
TLS for all matching house after we make
these configuration changes we'll run
the most vet to ensure there aren't any
other issues once we push our changes to
the upstream repository with git Anthes
config management we'll quickly detect
and apply the changes to our clusters
we'll run a little function helper to go
ahead and watch for those changes here
and that's how easy it is to apply a
policy and have anthos config management
synchronize it across all the clusters
in your environment finally we can
return to the connected services view
and after enough time passes for the
desired time span we can visually
confirm that we only had MPLS traffic
with the green locks four connected
services there are plenty of examples of
security guard rails you can set to
protect your application environment
with anthos start with a tutorial and
check out the docs to learn more we just
taken a short tour of anthos using a
sample deployment this is just a taste
of things for you to try so check out
our tutorial launch a sample deployment
and explore anthos for yourself
[Music]